[Music]
far cry 5 can be a bit of a mess
it's AI is spotty its narrative is all
over the place and most of its plot is
told inches from the camera by
characters with unclear goals and
confusing motivations but still I adore
this game because this is one of
Ubisoft's best open worlds yet flashback
to one year ago games published by
Ubisoft were easily recognizable the UIs
were cluttered the screens were littered
with waypoints and the mini maps were
covered in a multitude of icons
collectibles and miscellaneous tasks but
lately that hasn't been the case with
last year's Assassin's Creed origins
Ubisoft Montreal shied away from its
usual formula it removed much of the
crowded UI and completely erased the
infamous mini-map origins emphasized
exploration not by giving you tasks to
complete but by showing you distant
structures on the horizon and plenty of
things to distract you along the way it
encouraged discovery without an array of
icons across the screen and now with far
cry 5 Ubisoft continues that shift from
artificial checklists to digital
adventure it marks a promising move in
the publishers evolution as well as the
futures of its open-world franchises
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
changes in far cry 5 come on both a
macro and micro level as was the case
with origins far cry 5 askew is a mini
map in favor of a compass this change
lifted from the elder scrolls may seem
minor but it makes the world feel more
organic it takes your eyes off the UI
and directs them toward your
surroundings by removing the whole
climate our to reveal more of the map
trope Far Cry 5 goes a step further and
encouraging you to just wander around
Ubisoft Montreal uses sound design to
its advantage as well many times
throughout my playthrough I would hear a
gunshot in the distance upon following
it I might come across the expected
firefight other times I might stumble
upon a hostage situation gone bad less
frequently still I would come across a
lone hunter skinning her prey each
scenario was as exciting as the next
precisely because they all started the
same way but ended very differently
Ubisoft has been calling many of its
games anecdote factories for a while now
the games have numerous connected
systems you can toy with allowing you to
manipulate your enemy's abilities or
environments the fun comes from watching
them interact or just as often seeing
them collide in Far Cry 5 these water
cooler moments are more frequent and
thrilling
[Music]
now I think far cry 5 is Ubisoft's best
anecdote factory specifically because of
the changes it makes to exploration by
placing more emphasis on self-driven
discovery like breath of the wild did
last year everything feels more natural
you learn about characters through
rumors at the local bar you find new
hunting grounds via signs along the road
you find an isolated base-jumping
location travel through its canyons and
learn exactly why the locals named it
Devil's drop this leads me to far craft
five subtle yet effective environmental
storytelling in this version of Montana
most of the locals have doomsday bunkers
with ample amounts of canned food and
bottled water I'm reminded of Fallout 3
while exploring these subterranean
hideouts scribbled notes suggest what
happened in the final days before the
homeowners were captured by the Eden's
gate cult
Ubisoft Montreal expertly makes use of
context throughout this world take this
side quest as another example in the
early hours of my playthrough I saw this
window peppered with bullet holes
shortly after I heard the source of
these markings a cultist firing his
weapon at the hut after killing him I
went to investigate the building finding
a note he had written telling passerby
he had crossed the pond to try to shoot
the lock off of the huts door not only
did this explain his antics but also
hinted that there might be something
valuable inside it turns out there was
on the surface this encounter may seem
basic but consider this
I could have stumbled upon it in five
different ways I could have read the
note I could have heard the cultist
gunshots I could have seen the locked
door from his vantage point I could have
heard a rumour about the weapons stash
from an NPC across the map or as was
actually the case I could have seen the
tell-tale markings around the window the
quest works no matter your entry point
that to me is a very well-designed
open-world quest
this is in no way the only mission
designed to fit seamlessly into far cry
fives Montana but it is the only one I
want to dissect here because most of the
fun comes from finding these moments
yourself and watching them all unfold
none of this mentions your AI companions
or guns for hire parking back to Far Cry
2 these allies lending even more flavor
to your personal stories you develop
your own connections to these people as
you spend time with them my friend Luke
Smith may be dumb as hell take Exhibit A
but he's been with me through thick and
thin he's that friend I can't help hang
out with despite how often he gets me in
trouble
you and me may have both played Far Cry
5 but you might never have met Luke
Smith and you probably never will
finally we come to Far Cry fives main
narrative as I said before I'm
conflicted too much of it is exposition
spoken through religious diatribes
straight to your face it's also a
mishmash of about 15 different themes
none of which are given enough time to
pay off or even develop in some cases
but I do respect the main storyline for
how you come across it as with the rest
of Far Cry fives world these plot points
aren't waypoints on a mini map or boxes
to be checked off a list they occur
naturally you're captured somewhere in
the wilderness probably as you're
pursuing some other goal and taken to
the necessary story mission
I'm sure this annoys a lot of people who
would just rather ignore the main story
but I like it one of the biggest
problems in open-world games is how to
tell an overarching narrative when many
if not most players will be focused on
finding their own anecdotes far cry 5s
plot may not be perfect but as far as
how Ubisoft weaves it into the greater
world it's on the right track this is my
biggest overarching sentiment for the
game in general it's a promising shift
for a great series it's focused on
discovery and organic exploration make
me excited for farcry future and the
future of Ubisoft open worlds in general
the publishers internal Studios have
been experimenting with this sandbox
formula for years introducing new
features and design philosophies as they
go they keep the ones that work and they
discard those that don't the animal
commands in Far Cry 4 became the
centerpiece of
our Cry primal naval warfare introduced
an assassin's creed 3 became a
full-fledged game in Black Flag and now
the self-driven exploration of
Assassin's Creed origins has become for
me the defining fact our a far cry 5 and
I'm excited to see what comes next